let me show you something real quick
about communicating science if you code
or analyze data and need to communicate
results based on your work Cordo should
definitely be your friend quarter helps
you publish your technical work
beautifully anywhere by publish
technical work whether you're an analyst
scientist data scientist developer we're
often doing exploratory analysis and
development work in some IDE or notebook
or text editor when you have results to
share that work is the result of code
sometimes stored in multiple files and
notebooks with Cordo you start with your
code is the core of your work wherever
or however you prefer to do that and
then by beautifully we mean it's one
thing to build up these insights inside
a notebook or across multiple projects
and it's another thing to craft that all
into a succinct singular narrative ready
to share with others you may want to
combine narrative code the output of
that code that could be as simple as a
set of slides or text for printer for
the web or you may want to offer your
audience something interactive so they
can dig deeper into the data whatever
helps your audience understand these
insights best